Bheema queen is writing to say what
should i have available with me when i
meet with an investor I think yeah
obviously a great company story that
you're really proud of number one that
you could explain to your grandma
you should have stuff about market
market opportunity you should have stuff
about competitors if there's people out
there already doing what you plan to do
and while you're different you know key
thing is what do you do who you serve
and why you're different and you should
have the financial model certainly
though you know you don't have to do a
cup of 25 year plan but you should
certainly have a sketch down view of the
three year plan I'm pretty good detail
around this fiscal year and how you can
exploit the investment that they're
going to make my you know back to
heavens first point really where are you
going to invest that so you really
accelerate the growth of the business
how are you gonna deploy it and if they
get into you know if I was in my angel
days and they were raising a couple of
million dollars I'd say well tell me
where you can invest it you must have a
pretty good idea there what's your
marketing plan Laura I was to geographic
expansion what you reinvest on digital
mark and all these sort of things so you
need a pretty clear idea because you're
running the business they're going to
trust you as a management team and
you've got to have the confidence and
the plans in place to you're very
credible yeah I love it I mean there's a
number of resources and what needs to go
into a business plan there's a lot of
the common stuff I don't know if there's
anything that you guys offer on Sage on
the website or a blog post somewhere
that out lights and details but most
business plans are pretty standard and
there's a reason why all those sections
are in write is the reason why you need
to have the executive summary enough
financials and a management team the
operations plan and the sales and
marketing strategy all that stuff is
information that you as a business owner
should know throughout the business and
also investors will be interested in I
think the most important thing when
you're going to a meeting with somebody
is to be able to talk to the business
plan but not basically read it where a
lot of the pictures that I saw the the
the entrepreneur comes in they're like
okay here we go let's talk about my
sales and marketing plan and they're
like having always to refer back to
their notes
well if I wanted to read what was on
there I could just take it and read it
myself I'm interested in having a
conversation so you should be willing
and able to talk to the points in your
business plan and without having to look
through and memorize it I think that's
super important also I would use my ears
like any good salesperson you got to use
your ears every investor has their own
way of their own investment of
philosophy their own way of attacking
things and often we get locked into this
is my sales pitch and you don't deviate
from that where they may not care about
five of the things in your sales page
and so let them ask questions of you and
answer them openly honestly and give
them more contacts where they want that
context they haven't what are they if
you're gonna go do pitches it's so much
like girlfriend job in reality you got
anybody believe between 30 seconds and
two minutes to really grab their
attention and come you know jumping out
of their seats and I've got to have all
of this so if you're a chronic company
the best way to do that is to show them
the thing you're really proud about the
product just get your product out and
show them and again just be sensible
with I don't know if your product needs
Wi-Fi check all the Wi-Fi works test
drive everything so that when when you
get in there and it's show time
it's a show time they really remember
for the right reasons yeah so if you
could give them like a two minute three
minute product demo say start at the end
this is why we're different you'll have
grabbed their attention and then
everything else will follow from that
rather than just do the kind of standard
pitch or turn it up management team the
market and all that sort of standard
stuff so grab them around why you're so
excited and why you believe in in your
product I think it's a great way to go
yeah I love that point if you couldn't
visualize what's happening if you could
do some kind of visual demo I remember
reading about the guy who who
popularized the bulletproof vest he
would go to police stations and tell the
officer to shoot him in the chest and of
course he didn't it didn't go through
and that won them over just right there
that Wan AK
landed a whole bunch of deals for them
and so if you have a product that can be
demonstrated then
you absolutely want to bring into that
because it's something different
memorable bits of food products of them
going to be tasted bright anything that
you can show that more than just reading
off of paper or a PowerPoint slide helps
to make you stand out from the
competition
yeah the elevation the growth if you've
got real customers and customers are
great on this say to customers can you
send me a video 30-second clip of what
why you love my product and why we're
different and which competitors you
looked at and literally build build a
visual presentation and the best best
thing is showing the product yourself
bullet point vest is a great fruit point
but secondly if you haven't got that you
can stand out through customers so if
you know all these investors will say
we're customers like that love your
product this is real